- America as a nation
is founded on ideals
that are universal and built one
of the largest freaking
economy and largest military.
However, I think
that the people,
those who have lived under
prosperity for a long time,
and that's one of the
main contradictions,
is that they start
turning against the ideas
that made them
prosperous at the moment.
And so one of, I
would say, the ideals
of Ideas Beyond
Borders is making sure
that the American ideals
spread, that they can continue,
kind of like when you
send humans to Mars
so in that way,
humanity can continue
is to send the American
ideals all over the world
so in that way, these
ideals will continue.
(warm instrumental music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
we are on location
here at the local
studios in Miami.
And I am joined by the founder
of Ideas Beyond Borders,
but more importantly
a brand-new American
and my old friend,
Faisal Saeed Al Mutar.
It is good to see you, my man.
- Thank you so much
for having me again.
It's been a journey.
- Faisal, we were just
discussing you, well, first off,
you've been on this show.
You know, there's the Jordan
Peterson like 15 times,
there's the Gad Saad
probably 14 times,
the Douglas Murray
probably about 14 times.
You're close.
- I'm close, yeah.
- You're you're a
top fiver, for sure.
- Let make it 72 so in
that way... (laughs)
- That was a virgin joke.
That was a virgin joke.
- So that way maybe that
will make me closer
to heaven, yeah.
- It is...
Every time I sit down with
you, it's just an absolute joy
because you come from
a place in the world,
You come from Iraq.
Well, you know what,
give everybody the one-minute
recap on your life.
Can you do it in a
minute, the life story?
'Cause then we'll get
into all the other stuff,
but I think it sets up
such a beautiful story
that you're now, what'd you say?
One year American?
- 2019. It's been four
years, four years.
- You've been a
citizen for four years.
- Yeah, but then COVID hit-
- I've been treating you
like a brand-new citizen.
- Well, let's keep it that way.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Introduce me next time to
the best barbecue in town.
- Yeah. (laughs)
Give everybody like,
the one-minute story
that gets you to America.
- So I was born in Babylon
in Iraq, south of Baghdad,
then under the regime
of Saddam Hussein.
So I lived first
under Saddam Hussein
and then after the war, Al-Qaeda
took over my neighborhood.
I decided to be
outspoken against those
crazies at the time.
And then I ended
up on a death list,
also losing many
members of my family.
I left to Lebanon,
Lebanon to Malaysia,
Malaysia to eventually be
accepted in the United States
as a refugee in 2013.
And for me, like, the
reason why when I moved here
and seeing like, people not...
I thought at the
beginning that like,
people would
appreciate the values
that I used to fight
for when I was in Iraq.
And now 10 years later, I
think is that I was wrong.
- [Dave] Oof!
- Which is-
- That is a condemnation
of your new country.
- It's not a condemnation
of the country, I would say.
And that's, again, the journey
is that I've had an amazing,
pleasant experience in America.
I'm so grateful to be here.
And in fact, the word grateful
is even an understatement.
A year after I moved in, I was
hosted by an American family
for a year in Northern Virginia,
in which they treated
me as their kid.
The amount of support from
people like you and friends
and others who like,
elevated my voice
and made me part
of like, the scene.
I don't think this...
If I immigrate to
another country,
I would not have that experience
so I'm amazingly grateful.
And that's what I think is
the kind of the contradiction
is that there's my experience,
and I know it's the
experience of many thousands
if not tens of
thousands of immigrants.
And then there is those like
kind of champagne socialists
in Williamsburg and other
places who will be like,
"Oh, this country sucks,
and I cannot get my
latte at 2:00 PM."
And not only that is
that this country is,
they try to speak on behalf
of those who claim that
they are the victims,
and that pisses me
off to say the least.
- To say the least, yes.
- So one of the things
that I've been like,
kind of thinking about is that
how, like, the people here,
we need to figure out a way
to make them realize what
they're taking for granted.
And I think is that it's not
just my voice that matters,
but I think, I mean,
even with your show,
you've interviewed
a lot of people.
You've interviewed Yeonmi Park.
You interviewed a
lot of the voices
that perhaps speak
the same message
because the thing is like,
we don't even have to speak.
It is just true, so that's...
Sometimes I try not to speak
so much because I was like,
it's just like
it's self-evident.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- As written in
the US Constitution
or Declaration of
Independence, I guess.
- You are an American.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You studied for the
test. I got it, I got it.
Look, the first time we met was
the day that you did my show
for the first time,
right at the beginning,
so this was, I think, October
of 2015, if I'm not mistaken.
And Melissa Chen, our mutual
friend, introduced us,
and she said, "You know, you
should just have this guy
on the show and
just talk to him."
And I was like, "All right,
let's see what happens."
And here I met this guy who
was roughly new to America,
but I was like,
he loves freedom.
You wanna talk about classical
liberalism and ideas,
which now you've turned
into this nonprofit
and all of this stuff so you,
you just freaking
love this country.
I mean, it's just,
it just comes through
very clearly with you.
- Yeah, and the thing is like,
I loved this country
even before I came here,
even though my experience
with America is a mixed bag.
I mean, my first
introduction to America
was a Humvee in the front of
our house with US soldiers.
- What year was that?
- That was 2003 when the-
- Wow.
- 'Cause I was born
at the first war, like the, so
I guess my parents were busy
when there was no electricity
and they had sex and
I was born, but...
- So you were born during
the original Gulf War?
- The first Gulf War and then-
- So that was '92.
- End of 1990 and then
'91 is when I was born.
- Yeah.
- And then the
second one is 2003,
and I remember that
day very vividly
is that we were watching
the local television
and there was also
Iranian television
was intercepting in Iraq.
And they were telling
us that the US military
is being defeated in the South
and there are all these
soldiers being killed
and the Iraqis are winning
and stuff like that.
And then my brother was in the
second floor and he's like,
"There are American tanks
in front of our house."
And then within like, half an
hour, like the American tanks
were bombing my
elementary school,
which has a military
base of the Iraqi Army.
And within like, a couple days,
so that was in early April,
pretty much all of the highway,
which our house was in
front of the highway
where the US military
came into Baghdad.
And that was my first
introduction to the Americans.
- So what did you
think of America then?
- Honestly, it was more
like an alien feeling.
I'm like, "Who
are these people?"
And then, I mean,
thank goodness.
I mean, my parents
studied in the UK
so I was able to speak
English even though I still,
my English still depends
on how much margaritas
I've had during the day.
- I was gonna get
to margaritas later
because the true way that
I know you're an American,
you love a margarita
more than anyone I know.
- And that was, yeah,
thanks to Texas.
- It's technically
Mexican, but we'll...
- Well, it's a melting pot.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And so yeah, so the
first, I would say,
the first interaction
with an American
was an American soldier, and
they were like, very friendly.
They were kind of very
curious and they would go,
"We are here to like,
defeat Saddam Hussein."
However, things escalated
badly very quickly
so the reaction of the
American army to Iraqis
became more negative as they
started getting more attacked.
However, one of the benefits
that came in after the
war was the internet.
And I was, I mean, 2003, 2004,
the internet was not as
advanced as it is today.
But I was able to like, I
could just explore the world
through the internet and
see what America is like
and what the values
of America were.
So like, when all of that
civil wars was happening,
I was sitting at home
reading Thomas Jefferson
and "The Age of
Reason" by Thomas Paine
and "Common Sense"
and stuff like that.
And I was like, these are...
And the story like, of America,
at least the beginning story
and even like the Europe
33 Years' War, et cetera,
or the origin of
the Enlightenment
is what I think is the Middle
East is facing right now.
So it's like, the
foundings of America
and the civil wars that it
had and European civil wars
when Protestants and
Catholics, stuff like that,
is what I witnessed,
so it's just like,
we're 300 years behind.
- Right.
- And my goal is to
bring those values
into the region
that I came from,
which I think are the
reason why thousands
and hundreds of thousands
of people are prosperous
are the values that
founded America,
which I think are
values worth spreading.
- And you quite literally are
doing that with your life.
That's what Ideas
Beyond Borders does.
- Exactly, and I think that
even with my disappointment,
I mean, in a theoretical world,
let's say if America turns
against America, let's say,
I think that these values
are still worth defending.
So I think is that suppressing
the values of freedom.
America is itself an idea as
well as a country, and that's,
I think, what is very
unique about this country
is that there is, I mean,
with all my love for
Canadian neighbors,
but there's no Canadian idea.
But America as a nation
is founded on ideals
that are universal and built one
of the largest freaking
economy and largest military.
However, I think
that the people,
those who have lived under
prosperity for a long time,
and that's one of the
main contradictions
is that they start
turning against the ideas
that made them
prosperous at the moment.
And so one of, I
would say, the ideals
of Ideas Beyond
Borders is making sure
that the American ideals
spread, that they can continue
kind of like when you
send the humans to Mars
so in that way
humanity can continue
is to send the American
ideals all over the world
so in that way, these
ideals will continue.
- Does it blow your mind?
I mean, when you go back,
you were just interacting
not too long ago, and you
travel the world obviously.
When you go to the places
where it's not okay
to say what you think
and all of these things,
and you're translating books
so that people can
read these great texts
in the countries
that aren't as open
and then you compare
that to the people here,
you know, who are fighting
against freedom or, you know,
not really aware of how good
it is, must drive you nuts.
- It does.
I think it is because
that's, again,
one of the
contradictions is that
when you live under
freedom for a long time,
you start becoming cynical.
I think one of the main
things that I dislike
about kind of a specific
section of Americans,
obviously not all, as I
said, I think most Americans
are apolitical
and to some extent
they don't know what they have
and they don't necessarily
appreciate what they have,
but they don't necessarily-
- [Dave] It's a
function of the success.
- Yeah, and I think more
like those who are cynical.
Like, I remember I gave
a speech at UC Berkeley,
and I was talking about like,
my first experience
of a suicide bomber
and how literally the ecosystem
that allows this
thing to happen.
And one of the
students was like,
"Oh, we have the
same thing here."
I'm like, "Where?"
(Dave laughs)
All I see is like, a shawarma
restaurant that's fucked up.
I mean, the shawarma is like,
I don't know, made
from rabbit meat.
- You're telling me a
Berkeley shawarma place
isn't the best?
- No.
I recommend other places.
- Yeah.
- So I was like,
"Okay, seriously, like,
how delusional you must
think that you think
that life in America is bad
as it is in other places?"
Not, I mean, some
places obviously
are developed like America.
Norway, I just was in Norway.
It's a pretty cool country.
- Yeah.
- But to say like-
- It's also a very small,
largely homogenous country.
- Exactly.
And when they had start
having more immigrants,
even in Denmark and
other places, they
get confused, right?
Because they're
very homogeneous.
That's why even like systems
like democratic socialism,
whatever it's
called, can operate
because it's more like a
tribe that became a country.
But in America it's like,
you have all of these people
from different
parts of the world,
most of them able to
coexist and function.
I think it's pretty wonderful.
And because I come from
country and a place, a region
in which diversity is actually
a curse, not a blessing.
- [Dave] Mm-hmm.
- So many people fight
for a homogeneous place.
The Kurds are fighting
for their own place.
The Assyrians and the Christians
want their own small territory.
The Shias want their thing.
And so in a way it's like,
where I come from,
diversity is a curse.
And while here, because
the identity of the country
is built on ideals,
and unfortunately now
there's a whole identitarian
identity politics world
in which everything is
about race and stuff.
But I think the founding of
America was about ideals,
and we've seen it
functioning for 300 years,
and I think it's really
worth preserving.
I mean, I'm definitely
not giving up,
and I'm trying my best
now 10 years later
to be more involved in
the local conversation,
even though the Middle
East is enough headache.
I mean, I've had my fair share
of tequila every couple days
and it's never enough,
but I think is that,
I think there's a duty
of now being a citizen
and being welcomed by
this wonderful country,
I think it's also
part of my duty
to contribute here
any way I can.
- What's going on in Iraq now?
I feel like we don't
talk about Iraq.
Nobody knows what's going on.
You know, people look back
in hindsight at the war
in a very...
- Mostly negative.
- With very different
glasses than at the time.
You actually, in retrospect,
you're happy that...
I don't wanna put
words in your mouth,
but I think essentially happy
that the Americans
liberated from Saddam,
but that may not be connected
to exactly what's going on now.
- Yeah, I mean I support, I
wouldn't say in a direct way,
like, that I support the
war, but I think is that,
the options that are available.
I mean, I look at Iraq from
kind of the lowest of standards,
and it's mostly
because of its history.
Iraq started with a king
that the British installed
after the Ottoman Empire.
The king was killed
by the communists,
and then the socialists
killed the communists,
and then Saddam Hussein
killed the socialists,
and then Saddam
Hussein was attacked.
That's the history of Iraq.
- (laughs) In seven seconds.
- So this is, so when
you're trying to like,
kind of look at the ecosystem
of kind of the history,
that's the history.
And Saddam Hussein at his,
like the last years where,
like after the first
Gulf War was his worst
and was leading the
country into explosion.
The alternative, I think that
if the Iraq War never happened
or the US didn't intervene,
we would end up
exactly like Syria,
which is in a weird way now
when I came back to Iraq,
now there are Syria
refugees who live in Iraq.
So imagine how bad Syria is
that they come to Iraq
for refugee status.
So I went back to
Iraq after 13 years,
and I mostly went to the
Kurdistan region of Iraq,
even though I was
slightly on the borders
of federal Iraq and Mosul.
And it is really
mind-blowing how the country,
at least a part of
the country became.
Iraq, significantly,
has been stable,
relatively, over the
past couple of years.
The reasons are kind of
somehow sinister because,
but it's also a reason,
I guess, of application
of Milton Friedman
theories is that now
the political parties of
the Sunnis and the Shias
and the Kurds have enough
investments in the country.
So like some of them
own shopping malls
and restaurants and
all of that stuff.
So pretty much all of
them now are interested
in keeping the country stable.
- Mm-hmm.
- So now because they
have vested interests,
they no longer support suicide
bombers and stuff like that.
So that's why you don't
hear about Iraq on the news
because there has
not, as far as I know,
there has not been a
suicide attack since 2000,
like since the defeat of ISIS.
And as a result, the country,
a result of that stability,
there's now investments
and people coming in.
And weirdly, but not weirdly,
the Kurdistan region asked us.
So when I went back to Iraq
for the first time in 13 years,
so I met with the
government of Kurdistan,
at least a representative
of them and they were like,
"We would love you
to open an office,
an Ideas Beyond
Borders in this place.
We are very open
to Western ideas.
We would like, like,
whatever America has,
we actually want some of it.
We want to learn
about the experiment.
Like, translate more books,
work with our universities."
We started like a small
kind of venture funds
we call Innovation Hub
that support startups
and things like that so
moving towards privatization.
So in the grand
scheme of things,
I think Iraq is doing much
better than I left it,
which is itself a low standard,
but I think is that it
definitely has the potential
of becoming really a, I mean,
significantly much
better country,
even much better than
during Saddam Hussein.
So I think when people
try to, even with,
I had a debate on
"Slate Magazine,"
which Christopher Hitchens
used to write for,
about the Iraq war, but
"Slate" went far left.
- Sure, sure.
- After Hitchens.
- Like, pretty much
all the websites.
- Pretty much all the websites.
And the thing is
that most of the,
even the conversation was,
I mean, many of the people
who opposed the war,
and some are right reasons,
some are bad reasons,
but however, most
of them may try
to connect to domestic affairs.
Oh, Bush sucked, we don't
trust Bush and therefore,
or we don't trust the Republican
Party and things like that.
So eventually, I
mean, many Americans
cannot even name four
provinces in Iraq.
- Oh, I bet 99% can't
name probably one.
- So, but at the same time
have very strong
opinions about it
so it it's definitely
a complicated subject.
- Al Anbar Province.
How about that?
Pretty good, huh?
- That's a good one.
I mean, that's the
one where America
did not have a good time.
But yeah, with that
being said, it's like,
I mean, we've seen that also
with Afghanistan is that...
And that's, I would say,
is like one of the reasons
why I think people like
me have to take a lead.
I mean, I don't
believe in saviors.
I think that people
from the region
have to fix their own region,
which is the reason I
started my organization.
It's the reason why I started
support many organizations
in Iraq and stuff like that.
In fact, my goal of
my organization is
ceasing to exist.
- Yeah.
- Like, we don't wanna be,
we don't wanna build
this bureaucracy
in which you just wanna
advocate for the cause
and you keep raising
money just because
there is an organization
you wanna maintain.
So eventually I think
the people there have to.
I think America with
all its mistakes
allowed the room
for that to happen.
There's now free press
or freedom of speech
when I know it's under
attack even here.
That, I think, is like the seed
of building a
functional society.
It's the seed of innovation.
It's the seed of progress.
And not progress towards hell
in a way that progressives
in America are,
but like, but actual progress.
And I think that
America built that city.
Even in Afghanistan,
now we're working
with like, underground schools.
Like, we built a network
of schools of teachers
who educate girls underground
from different houses
all over the place.
And honestly, I'm like, "Why
the hell you do what you do?
Like, what's really
the motivation?"
And they're like, "We
are the first women
to ever been to school
in most of our tribe.
And most of the reason
why we went to school
is because America
came to our country."
So in that kind of 20 years,
some of these women
went to school,
they went to college, et cetera,
and now they feel it's
their duty to make sure
that the girls of tomorrow
don't end up being illiterate.
So that is a success story
of the American intervention.
The American withdrawals,
however, that's another story.
But I think is that, I think
that we can always talk
about the negatives
of the intervention,
but I am seeing like, even when,
and I would love to
take you to Kurdistan,
and I gift for you from
Kurdistan, is that you will see
that people are appreciative.
And I think what
happens with the Kurds
is that they took leadership.
America did what it can,
but then at the same time
they're like, we
want our country,
our place to be developed.
And they took leadership and
they made it happen, so I-
- So in effect they have a...
I know it's not
technically a country
by international standards,
but they have a country
in essence, right?
Like in-
- To some extent.
I mean, it's a
semi-autonomous region.
- I mean, not
according to Turkey
and not according
to Iraq, I guess.
- But the politics, I mean,
that needs like six bottles
of tequila, just the...
But to make it very,
very simple is that,
I mean, there are multiple...
I know that's not the
official narrative,
but there are different
types of Kurds.
- Mm-hmm.
- So that's also part of it.
I mean, even the
Kurds themselves speak
different languages.
Generally speaking, the
Kurds of Iraq and Iran
speak a similar language
and have a similar heritage,
and the ones in Turkey and Syria
have a different heritage,
different language.
The ones in Turkey in particular
who are supported a lot
by the Soviet Union,
so there's a major
group called the PKK,
which is mostly communist,
like, nut jobs in my opinion,
who have extreme differences
with the ones in Iraq and Iran.
So there are a lot
of kind of issues
within unity for the Kurds.
However, the Kurdistan
region of Iraq
is kind of the most successful.
It's institutionalized.
They have their own parliament,
and it's definitely
a success story,
which I think many other Kurds
from the neighboring places
can look up to as a model
that they can follow.
And so if you are an Arab Iraqi,
you technically need a residency
when you enter the
Kurdistan region of Iraq.
So kind of, it's not
a visa, but you need.
If you are an Iraqi American
and then there's like, you can,
even if you're Arab, you
can stay however you want.
But, so it is
technically, I mean,
the Kurdistan region of
Iraq, it's technically a...
I mean, you see more
flags of Kurdistan there
than you see flags of Iraq.
However, there are many Arabs,
and there are many investors
from the Gulf States
and others building fancy
hotels and restaurants.
And so the Kurds there found out
that it's good to do
business with the Arabs
and not be in that
constant state of turmoil.
- So in some ways it's, you
sort of hinted at this earlier,
you basically said it,
I mean, capitalism,
the ability to just
trade with each other
sort of is the first nugget
to getting to everything else.
That people suddenly
realize, oh, I've got a shop.
I've got employees,
there's people around me.
Like, there's something
worth protecting.
- 100%, I'm 100% a believer
in the kind of the
how connectedness.
I mean even now with
Saudi Arabia, I mean, yes,
we can talk a lot about MBS,
but if you look at it from
the core, like Saudi Arabia,
because of the fact oil, they
wanna diversify from oil.
Before they have oil, they
can say whatever they want.
Like, it's our oil. You
don't like us, go to hell.
Now they are, they want to
open up for investments.
To open up for investments,
you need to liberalize
and you need to be open to
capitalism and the fact that
when you're gonna bring in
people from Florida and LA
and everywhere, they would
like to bring their girlfriend
or their wife or they'd
like to bring the husband.
So as a result, they have
to, so like in a way,
the economic freedom or the
incentive to create investments
is opening up Saudi Arabia,
which is the most conservative
place in the region.
So I think it's that, that's
why I'm wearing this dollar.
Even though it's
actually the pencil,
which talks about how
like the pencil itself
is made from different
elements and it needed the work
of multiple people from
different countries
to work together
to make the pencil.
And that's, I think,
is essential piece
if we want to move the region.
And that's a great thing about
investments and capitalism.
It reduces dependency.
Most of these regions,
and because of
these shitty international
development organizations
like the UN and all of that,
what they do is that
they create dependency.
They give all, here's
these, here's some food,
here's some stuff, but
then they create a system
in which you have to
constantly give money to the UN
for people not to starve.
- It's just incredible
'cause it's what we have
with all of our welfare state,
and then we've exported it
into these giant
globalist organizations.
- With, in some
cases, bad ideas.
I mean, I think the study,
yeah, in Iraq about,
they built a school for like,
people who identify as girls
or something like
that and people-
- In Iraq?
- Yeah. (laughs)
And people have no idea
how to translate that
in the first place.
- Oh my God.
- So there is also
a backlash now,
a significant
backlash, I would say,
against some of the
ideologies that come
with these international
development organizations
that they kind of give
you a bag of food,
but also comes with
the whole baggage of-
- But you have to dress
your son up like a woman.
- Yes, I mean, that will go
far away in Anbar province.
- Yeah.
- (laughs) So there is
definitely a backlash.
And we try to, I mean, as
an organization that's new
and we try to work,
we have our ideals,
but we try to work
within the region itself.
And even now, I mean, the
conversation is very difficult,
like, to tell people
to Westernize.
But even if you tell
them to Westernize,
what version of the West
they should Westernize to.
So the thing is that the
main thing is to get people
into these ideals
and let them make up.
And I don't think, like,
the ultimate goal of freedom
when people get to know
about classical liberalism,
they end up subscribing to the
woke totalitarian ideology.
I think is that they
become self-evident
and they were like,
"We want to keep that."
- So that's actually
a great segue
to where I wanted to go next,
which is that when I first met
you, there was a really huge
sort of secular humanist
movement in America.
- [Faisal] Oh,
the good old days.
- You and I went to the
Reason Rally in D.C. together,
and I spoke at
the National Mall.
And this is at the sort
of height of Sam Harris,
and you mentioned Hitchens
before and Dawkins.
And there was this
feeling of like,
you could escape all
of the old of religion
and create this sort of
perfect secular thing,
except it's pretty
much fallen apart.
And I suspect that most
of your support these days
is somewhat connected
to people of faith
more than purely
secular organizations.
Is that fair to say?
- Both, I mean, I would say
where most of our support
comes up from the
classical liberal world.
That would be like Atlas
Network and kind of the,
and people who support
like the libertarian
classical liberal space.
I would say very
little of our support
comes from that humanist world.
In fact, that secular
humanist world
generally teared
against us, is that-
- Right.
- They were like,
oh, you're trying to spread
the ideas of capitalism
that led to slavery
and shit like that.
- Right, so the people that
you thought were your...
that's what I was trying get to.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- People that you thought
were your greatest allies,
probably, when you got here
and me as a liberal back then.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. They turned-
- They were the ones that ended
up turning on us the most.
- And they were
supporting, in fact,
the groups that were
going against us.
So because of
cultural relativism.
That was one of, I would
say the, central tenets
of these groups that
were associated with
is that they were,
they hated the values that
made this country prosperous.
So in a way is that they,
most of their criticism
is of America than
other cultures.
So in the moment you say,
"Oh, there is issues happening
in the Islamic world
or in the Middle East"
and things like that, they
always try to drive it back.
But do you know
America is racist?
And do you know that like if-
- You were usually thinking
about that in Iraq.
- Yeah, yeah.
- In '97, weren't you?
Come on.
- Exactly.
It's like when I was young,
when I was in '97, I was like,
"Oh shit, maybe I
should stay in Iraq.
Why would I move to New York?"
- Right.
- And so that is, generally
these kind of groups,
I think that the...
I mean, there are secular
groups even within like,
the Ayn Rand crowd,
the objectivists
that were not originally.
So like, the secular
world is kind of divided.
It's between those who, mostly
on the left, unfortunately.
And there are those who are
like, kind of the objectivists,
and they are clashing.
That's why you don't
see them being invited
to these largely kind
of humanist places.
And I think that it's
generally terrible for...
'Cause I see a separation
between the importance
of separating religion
from the state, which is,
'cause I've been the victim
when that didn't happen,
in which the Sunnis
of their own version
want to make it the case
and the Shias want to
make the case, et cetera.
I think that kind of, these
values can be separated
from concepts like
the welfare state.
And in America, unfortunately,
sometimes many of these
things comes as a package.
It's like, in order for you
to believe in capitalism,
you also, some cases you have
to have a stance on abortion
and have a stance on guns.
- Right, right, right.
- And have...
- These things are
all deeply connected.
- They're all connected
because, you know,
like the embryos have
guns and then they...
So like, everything
has to be connected.
I see that like, even
within the Founding Fathers
of the United States when,
like part of the reason
why America was established
as a secular nation
was they were afraid
of different factions
of Christianity
would actually take over
and then they would be,
no, the Jews are not allowed
and the Irish Catholics
are not allowed.
And so these concepts
unfortunately like,
they were champions for the
wrong reasons by a lot of people
within kind of the socialists
and stuff like that
who wanted to, in order for
them to sell the package,
they were like, okay, you
have to be a socialist
and join us.
- Right.
- And then when I was telling
them within this crowd
that actually think that
socialism is bullshit,
then they were like
saying to me that,
"No, you're not a true
humanist and you're not..."
- Right, you're a
sellout, basically.
- You're a sellout.
- You're not brown anymore.
- Yeah, I became Betty White.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- So the thing is that,
that they wanted very, like,
I think they have utilized
secularism in a way,
and like these ideas to
sell their own bad ideas
because I believe that
there can be a separation.
And I think that even the
values that I advocate for,
whether in Iraq or America
is mostly coexistence.
I mean, the thing is
that I'm interested,
so capitalism we
know for centuries
has been a very driving force
of getting people
to work together.
When you connect countries,
that leads to more coexistence.
When you remove the
one version of religion
to kind of dictate
how other people live,
that leads to coexistence.
So well, the socialists
don't want coexistence.
Socialists want dominance.
So I think that unfortunately
many of these things
get mixed up, in
America in particular.
Like, you can go to places
like Norway or Sweden
where these things
are a bit separated.
Like, there's kind of
a history of secularism
outside the socialist
forces and they don't...
Like, you can meet a
liberal party in Sweden,
and they are very
confident being secular
but also support free markets.
There's no, they don't see
any contradiction in this,
but here-
- Well, even in England
if you say you're a liberal,
it has a different connotation-
- Exactly.
- Than saying in...
That's why I can't say
it in America anymore
with a degree of like-
- Of confidence.
- Well, I just have
to then explain it
for an hour every time.
- Yeah, because I mean,
they hijack these terms,
and I think now it's
becoming so clear.
We can see these divisions
between kind of
the older Democrats
and kind of a younger
generation of Democrats
in which those, like,
from the older side
who kind of followed what
they thought was liberal
look at these guys
and they're like,
"You guys are crazy."
- Mm-hmm.
- So there's
divisions here as well
in terms of kind of liberalism.
But I think, I mean, to kind of,
if I see the segue
of your question,
is that the kind of the
secular atheist world
led us to what we
have right now.
And I know Peter Boghossian
is now having questions
about that because he was,
unlike me who was like,
he was an advocate for atheism
as like front and center.
- He wrote a book called "A
Manual for Creating Atheists."
And now most of his
friends are usually,
well, certainly people of faith,
but mostly evangelical
Christians, I think.
- Yeah, so he is kind of,
he started questioning
whether that would be
the kind of the outcome
of what they were working for.
I think there is
some truth to that.
I think is that we just,
we aim to destroy religion,
but we had no alternative idea.
We just know what we hated,
but we know what we stood for.
And if you looked
at even reasonality
in many of these places, I mean,
now we look at it in hindsight.
There were places of kind
of hate and resentment.
They were like, "We hate
the Christian right.
We hate this, we hate that."
But if you ask them about like,
what did they actually stood
for, it was very blurry.
What I think is that...
But if you think about it now,
many of us who were there,
you, Michael
Shermer, me, Melissa,
Peter Boghossian
and all that stuff
who used to be kind of critical
of the religious right,
all of us move to become
critical of the woke left.
And I think it's that, it's
not a surprise that is the case
because we actually
understood what liberalism is
and what we stood for.
And I think it's
that it should be,
more people should
be more outspoken
than what we have right now.
- Let's finish with this.
As a proud new American, and
you love your American jackets
and your American shirts
and your American hats
and all of those things.
When you see the type of
political fighting we have now,
which we don't have
the sectarian sort
of house to house,
we're gonna kill you fighting.
We certainly don't have that
yet, but we've had our riots.
We have our cities burning down
at times, all of that stuff,
which always feels to me like
it could just be turned on
at any given moment.
You know, there could just
be some incident any day,
today, that turns
it on tomorrow.
How worried are you that where
the way we deal with politics
or the cultural issues could
lead us to basically being
this sort of sectarian, you
know, we're a huge country,
but basically
being this very odd
sectarian cannibalized blob?
- I'm worried and
not at the same time.
I mean, not to quote
Bill Clinton, but I
mean, he said like,
I think if I'm
quoting him is that,
"The worst of America can be
solved by the best of America."
So I mean, now I've been
to 42 states as far,
and I've talked to many people
from different people
of the political aisle.
I became a US citizen,
there were people
who support Trump
that congratulated me.
There are people
who support Hillary,
that support the
Democratic Party.
So I think it's that, I mean,
America is a wonderful country.
I think most people
cognitively or not cognitively
understand that
and believe that.
I mean, many people
when they're like,
"I'm moving this country
to move to Canada."
Like, are you
fucking kidding me?
You're not moving to Canada.
- Nobody goes.
- You live in Jersey City and
you enjoy your life there.
Like, don't tell me
you're moving to Canada.
So I think many people,
when you take it,
when they are pressured,
I think they understood
that this country is great.
However, there is kind of
a sense of virtue signaling
of cynicism and stuff like
that to show, to give a sense.
I think that's what the woke
kind of gave to some extent.
They give a sense of
moral superiority.
So everybody wants
to have that feeling
sort of like wearing a big cross
walking in the streets of
Beirut during the Civil War.
It's like, it gives
you like a sense of...
So I think that, so that's
my kind of optimistic side.
My least, my kind
of worried side
is that we have seen this
before, is that, I mean,
I would say at least
within the political arena,
we have reached a level,
I mean, even encountered
terrorism circles.
It's called the level
of dehumanization.
So it's like you look at the
other side as kind of the enemy
and that deserves
to be destroyed.
That itself is like
a seed of wars.
Things can happen
as result that.
- Yeah, you can do
almost anything-
- Because that's like,
I mean, what we see
in the Middle East
and even Balkan places
and stuff like that,
that is like when people
reach dehumanization level
and then the rule of law
gets destroyed and then people
start killing each other.
So I think it's that America,
at least in the political
arena where is observed,
and the thing is
that, and in America,
everything can become
like an industry of sorts.
So like, there is an
industry of polarization
that wants people to
destroy each other
and then claim that
they are the savior.
I'm saving you from
the other side.
I mean, when I grew up
in Iraq, there's, I mean,
when people understand like,
how did Al-Qaeda and ISIS
spread in these places, right?
ISIS took over the 1/3 of
Iraq in like a couple weeks.
And the message of
ISIS at the time,
how they recruited
people was not that,
oh, we're here to destroy
the Christian West.
It was, I am here to defend
you from the other side.
And then so all of these
kind of extremists rise
in the ecosystem
that allows them
to be viewed as the saviors.
And I think America
is not there yet,
but I think there are definitely
seeds for that to happen.
And you are doing your
best and I will do my best
to make sure that
this doesn't happen,
whether it's through
marketization,
Ideas Beyond Borders
or me individually.
- Or through margaritas.
- With margaritas. (laughs)
- Good to see you, my friend.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues,
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.